Tom I want to just begin with you can
you just define what exactly is the
opportunity for Apple in the streaming
music space well they've been leaders in
the music space of the biggest music
account in the world for everyone in the
music business and they're being
threatened now as the music business
moves from physical and digital
downloads or ownership or a sales model
into a streaming or an access model Adam
Citterio I'm one of you can comment a
little bit on what is the pretend what
is that proposed the price point and why
would the Apple service have an
advantage over Spotify or Pandora or
Deezer I think that advantage that
Apple's gonna have in the end is going
to be its scale and then you're gonna
have the resources to throw a huge
amount of marketing money at it they're
gonna have make sure some partnerships
with some big-name artist they've
partnered with bands like u2 in the past
but in some ways is gonna be very
similar it's gonna be at $10 a month you
can get all the access to all the songs
that they have in their library and you
can kind of share songs it's similar to
what beats music has now and so
ultimately it's gonna be up to Apple to
kind of convince people to either switch
from Spotify or probably more
importantly is they're gonna be going
after the people who haven't yet started
paying for a subscription music service
before and so they want to move over
people who do iTunes downloads to get
them now paying 10 bucks a month Adam
very quickly there's a lot of noise
behind you and it seems like there are
people protesting they're wearing masks
can you tell us what's going on there
it's it's a little bit of a scene you
guys got a protester here you but then
it's mostly developers coming in this is
a big event for Apple and a lot of
engineers and software coders come in to
learn about the newest things that
they're building so that they can build
apps for the phone for the watch iPad
things like that Thomson I'm just
wondering if you could describe the
different pieces of the music business
because you've got subscribers you've
got downloaders you got people by actual
physical music just run us through the
business there's six ways that people
consume music right now traditional
radio FM AM radio it's one way they can
the oldest way physical record sales CDs
and vinyl which as you know is growing
it over 50% a year downloads digital
downloads which is what Apple is the
magis iTunes and others but iTunes is
about eighty-five to ninety percent of
it worldwide
then there's streaming services and they
come in two different types ad supported
streaming services like YouTube and
Spotify free and VEVO and other ones
that are subscription which is Spotify
its domain also but Deezer is in there
in title and there are many more coming
online now so is Apple's new service
trying to do too much because it's
stitched together from its existing
service which includes the iTunes
download its two-year old internet radio
service and that hasn't having much of
an impact and also the beats
subscription music service it's a little
bit of everything as opposed to a simple
business model that say Pandora has or
that Deezer has or actually on the
contrary the reason why Apple has been
successful is because they've created an
ecosystem where people can live with
their music in every possible way they
can store it in their cloud they can
download if they want to download they
can listen to radio and now they can
stream the same way
Spotify will stream to and I disagree
that there will be disrupting Spotify or
any of the existing players there's a
big advantage to early movers in the
digital business in every business but
especially in digital I think that they
can tap they'll be launching on 800
million devices if they activate half of
them and they can convert at forty
percent which is how much Sirius XM
converts they have they have
confidence of their users that are in
their ecosystem people are spending that
much they have credit cards of almost
all of the 800 million they're gonna
give a three month free subscription I
believe and so at the end of that three
months if they can convert at the 40
percent that SiriusXM converts that
we're looking at quadruple the music
business in terms of what streaming is
and it's not going to come from Spotify
users it's going to come from new people
from new people from iPhone users Adam I
want to ask you Apple has been
negotiating licensing deals with major
labels right up until the last minute we
heard from a Sony Music that this
announcement today will definitely have
to do with Apple streaming service can
you give us an update on that yeah these
are the negotiations went down to the
wire Apple has been negotiating for
different things like it's trying to get
exclusive contents different access to
different things to kind of
differentiate the service but in the end
I think it's gonna come down to still
being a $10 a month service there is
talk earlier in the year about it being
a little bit less expensive than once
what some of the other services offer
that's not that didn't end up being able
to work out so a lot of the details
today will really flush out Tom I want
to ask you about music industry revenue
because you let the look at it on a per
user basis give us the outlook here in
the new music business which is an
attention oriented business you have to
look at things on a per user basis so
how much does a user spend on music in a
year either in terms of advertising
through their attention or directly
through subscription revenue and it
turns out the ARPU average revenue per
user is highest far higher than digital
downloads and three to four times higher
than physical sales when when it comes
to subscription services and as much as
10 times as much as ad supported
services at this point in time I need to
ask you Taylor Swift her music off of
Spotify the Beatles are not available
for streaming anywhere I know they're
available on iTunes if you buy the album
what is the level of support within the
music industry for streaming well the
music industry is very excited about it
there are many artists who are looking
at it from the old-school perspective of
when you change the mentality from a
record buying mentality to attention
mentality an average revenue per user
mentality how do we maximize revenues
from the overall people to increase the
overall value of music it requires a
different way to look at it artists
haven't been able to put their arms
around that yet but part of the reason
is the scale is so small there's only 41
million subscribers worldwide in the
last year there's only seven point six
or seven in America
I'm sure it's up to ten million now in
America but what if Apple comes on
strong we could be at fifty or a hundred
just in America which is amazing there's
only 27 million subscribers to Sirius XM